ob das thema nun kommunikation lautet
bildung oder marktwirtschaft der
philosoph norbert bolz scheut sich nie
eine eigene meinung zu vertreten auch
wenn die mehrheit anders denkt und
obwohl er über den politisch eher linken
adorno promoviert wurde ist bolts
portiert liberal und er ist ein
erklärter gegner von politikern
correctness und ein eifriger beobachter
unserer medien spannend katar gentinetta
hat den streitbaren gelehrten eingeladen
norbert bolz das fernsehen ist wie das
wetter
keiner ist dafür verantwortlich meistens
ist es schlecht und jeder interessiert
sich dafür
dieser satz stammt von ihnen jetzt nicht
gerade unkritisch warum sind sie denn da
nun es gibt dafür mindestens zwei gute
gründe erstens bin ich eitel genug und
so eine einladung nicht einfach nein
sagen zu können und zum anderen gehört
zu einer generation die mit dem
fernsehen groß geworden ist so wie meine
eigenen kinder mit dem internet groß
geworden sind bin ich mit dem fernsehen
groß geworden die ard hat sich fast in
dem augenblick zusammengeschlossen
damals als ich geboren wurde und so was
prägt fernsehen war für mich das
leitmedium und dann nehme ich auch die
entsprechenden leiden angesichts des
meistens wirklich schlechten programms
in kauf das sagt er nichts über die
schweiz denn das programm hier kennt
nicht das heißt sie leiden wenn die
zuschauer aber wenn sie im fernsehen
selbst hin scheinen sie nicht zu leiden
da sind sie eigentlich immer sehr
angenehm und also sehr groß unterwegs
und scheuen sich ja nicht ihre meinung
kundzutun
das stimmt das hängt auch ein bisschen
mit dem alter zusammen es ist eine der
wenigen positiven erfahrungen die man
mit fortschreiten alter macht dass man
mehr riskieren kann die älter man wird
umso größere risiken kann man eingehen
und das tue ich dann auch also ich habe
mich mit 50 entschlossen das ist jetzt
gerade mal zehn jahre her nur noch das
zu schreiben was ich wirklich denke und
nicht das zu schreiben was andere gerne
von mir
würden und das bedeutet auch dass ich
meine meinung mittlerweile ziemlich
ungeschützt sage und riskiere dann auch
entsprechend viele menschen damit zu
verärgern
heißt das dass das was sie vor 50
geschrieben haben heute nicht mehr
schreiben würden oder dazu nicht mehr
stehen
es gibt ja einen bis sommer sagen eine
wissenschaftliche dimension dessen was
ich gearbeitet habe ich bin ja auch
einfach nur ein wissenschaftler und
viele dieser eher wissenschaftlichen
arbeiten vor allem eine
habilitationsschrift die würde ich auch
heute noch gerne so schreiben wie sie da
steht da will ich gar nichts
zurücknehmen nein aber man kommt ja vor
allen dingen als medienwissenschaftler
sehr rasch immer in politische
diskussionen nicht nur medien politische
diskussionen und da muss ich ganz
einfach sagen hat der druck der wenn man
so will der linken öffentlichkeit auch
auf mein bewusstsein gewirkt und ich
habe also lange jahre mit großem stolz
in zeitungen publiziert die eine sehr
klare erwartungshaltung an das hatten
was man das sagt und schreibt und ich
habe diese erwartungen meistens dann
auch erfüllt das würde ich sicher heute
nicht mehr tun haben sie einen gedanken
von dem sie sagen würden den würden sie
auch so heute nicht neu sei das gibt es
sicher ich habe ja keinen
enzyklopädisches gedächtnis alles dessen
was sie hier geschrieben habe es ist
eher umgekehrt so hoffentlich erschreckt
sie das nicht zu sehr dass ich in dem
augenblick in dem ich ein buch
abgeschlossen habe mich überhaupt nicht
mehr für das thema interessiere es wird
wahrscheinlich genügen dass wir ein
bisschen darüber diskutieren können was
ich da noch erinnern kann
aber für mich ist ein buch ein thema das
sich abarbeiten will dass sie mir selber
klar machen will
und wenn ich denke ich habe die lösung
gefunden ist das buch fertig und dann
bin ich schon bei einem neuen thema also
da kann es durchaus passieren und das
ist sicher auch geschehen dass sich
viele dinge heute anders anpacken würde
anders sehen würde aber von den büchern
die mir heute noch wichtig sind würde
ich eigentlich nichts sagen dass er
etwas zurückzunehmen haben
sprechen wir über eines ihrer bücher das
abc der medien sie sind professor für
medienwissenschaften an der technischen
universität berlin
das abc klingt eben wie gesagt das ist
alphabetisch es geht durch die
wichtigsten themen durch sie machen da
relativ scharfe angriffe gegen die
medien was ist das eigentlich was sie
ihren studenten zuallererst mit geben
wenn sie sich mit medien befassen was
was finden sie müssen ihre studenten
mitnehmen
ja was sie mitnehmen von meinen eigenen
veranstaltungen das kann ich leider
nicht steuern
aber es gibt in der tat eine botschaft
und die hat mit medienwissenschaft gar
nichts zu tun und die würde ich in jedem
anderen fach genauso geben und die
versuche ich auch meinen eigenen kindern
mit zu geben nämlich macht nur das was
euch wirklich begeistert und mit dieser
erwartungen die studenten bin ich
unendlich weit entfernt von dem was
heute studien praxis ist ich will da
nicht jammern über die universität heute
aber dieses leuchten in den augen
das sieht man doch nur noch sehr sehr
selten wir waren damals in den 70er
jahren wo er sich selber student war
sicher dumm und dreist und haben
glaubten alles besser zu wissen als die
professorin stadt mal was von ihnen zu
lernen
aber wir waren jedenfalls begeistert und
das scheint mir doch die grundbedingung
dafür zu sein dass man überhaupt
irgendetwas sinnvolles in welchem fach
auch immer studiert und dann auch
ausarbeitet und das wäre für mich das
größte überhaupt wenn es mir gelingen
würde dem ein oder anderen zu begeistern
für wissenschaft überhaupt und daneben
auch für die wissenschaftliche lehre ist
ihnen denn die wissenschaft an sich
wichtige oder versuchen sie müssen ja
versuchen diesen jungen menschen etwas
über die medien mit zu geben
natürlich nein das ist ja klar ich
unterhalte mich auch nicht über das
elend der deutschen universität mit
ihnen
wir reden immer klartext zur sache es
geht immer nur um inhaltliches ich
spreche noch nicht einmal über methoden
fragen und ähnliches wir haben immer
sehr konkrete handfeste themen aber ich
versuche natürlich schon ihnen kontakt
zu vermitteln beispielsweise mit texten
und theorien die ich für bedeutsam halte
damit nehme ich natürlich einfluss das
ist ganz klar ich will das auch durchaus
tun ich versuche das so transparent wie
möglich zu halten
und insofern wäre für mich der große
leer erfolg eigentlich der und dann
lernen erfolgt der studenten
wenn sie diese angst vor theorien
überwinden würden denn das ist auch ganz
selbstverständlich leider gottes gilt
das auch für meine eigenen bücher obwohl
ich mir immer mühe gebe sie abc artig zu
buchstabieren dass sie die meisten leute
dann doch abschrecken
also sicher nicht jetzt die zuschauer
dieser sendung aber das ist eben doch
immer noch wissenschaft und das heißt
für wenige
ich versuche daran zu arbeiten und
möchte ein bisschen größeres publikum
erreichen
auch ganz normale leute aber das ist gar
nicht einfach
sie sagen zum beispiel wir erfahren die
welt durch medien
das ist ja eine relativ klar wir können
nicht überall zur gleichen zeit sein wir
können auch nicht alles persönlich
erfahren
ist das aus ihrer sicht problematisch
oder ist das wertvoll
problematisch ist deshalb nicht weil es
alternative los ist es gibt keinen
anderen zugang zur welt als über die
medien und das betrifft ja auch gerade
die sogenannten eigenen erfahrungen die
man macht alles was man eigenen
erfahrungen sammelt wo auch immer ist
gefiltert durch irgendwelche scripts
durch irgendwelche drehbücher die man an
sich angelesen hat die man vielleicht
sogar im fernsehen selber sich als
assimiliert hat und durch diese schemata
hindurch schauen wir die welt an
und die medien sind sicher die
wichtigste kraft bei der ausbildung
dieser schemata durch die wir
notgedrungen die welt wahrnehmen und das
gilt eben auch für wissenschaftler ja
also niemand ist dagegen gefällt meinen
sie denn dass diese jungen leute die bei
ihnen sitzen gar keine authentischen
erlebnisse haben wenn sie beispielsweise
dass die welt reisen ja quasi die
erlebnisse die sie in der welt haben
gefehlt hat wahrnehmen durch das was sie
aus den medien schildern niemandem zu
nahe treten vielleicht gibt es menschen
die authentische erfahrungen machen ich
nicht
und ich versuche den studenten auch ein
bisschen sensibilität zu vermitteln
genau für dieses thema der medien
vermittelt hat der eigenen erfahrungen
denken sondern ganz trivial als beispiel
sie machen einen urlaub in rom oder in
spanien oder wo auch immer in kreta sie
würden nichts sehen wenn sie nicht
irgendeinen dumont reiseführer oder so
irgendetwas dabei hätten man würde es
buchstäblich nichts sehen oder sie gehen
in ein museum
sie sehen buchstäblich gar nichts wenn
man ihnen nicht hilft zu sehen gehen sie
mal in den impressionisten ausstellung
oder wer auch immer von kubismus ganz zu
schweigen
und das ist ja nur allererste phase
moderner malerei sie kriegen überhaupt
nichts zu sehen also im sinne von
unmittelbare persönliche erfahrung wenn
sie nicht vorher ein bisschen gelesen
haben über was hat picasso da gemacht
und wie kommt es zu der kubistischen
darstellung oder futuristischen technik
und dann zieht man plötzlich also
insofern würde ich eher sagen es ist
eine positive sachverhalt die medien
öffnen einem die augen und medien sind
ja eben nicht nur fernsehen radio oder
film gerade bücher sind über
jahrhunderte hinweg das große leitmedium
und sie spielen ja auch immer noch eine
gewisse rolle da spreche ich ja
natürlich einfach er von informationen
also information brauchen wir damit wir
überhaupt etwas erkennen können
aber sie haben vorher ja auch eben quasi
dieser authentizität in frage gestellt
auf der anderen seite sagen sie jetzt
dass der journalismus dazu neigt
subjektiv und authentisch also subjektiv
zu argumentieren stadt objektiv also
quasi aus der eigenen sicht heraus ohne
zu versuchen darzustellen was ist
sondern gleich die eigene meinung mit
hier einzubringen und bleibt dann leben
wir uns immer auf alle versuchen wir
trotzdem darüber zu sprechen und auf der
anderen seite sagen sie dass der
journalismus immer das authentische
sucht
wie ist denn das möglich wenn das
authentische nach ihnen eigentlich gar
nicht möglich sein dass das ist
selbstverständlich nicht nur die
journalisten suche nach dem
authentischen die meisten menschen
suchen nach dem authentischen und
deshalb ist der begriff ja der kult
begriff unserer zeit ja also ich würde
sagen
neben nachhaltigkeit ist authentizität
der absolute spitze
den wert unserer zeit geworden und das
liegt meines erachtens daran dass es
gerade diese erfahrung nicht mehr gibt
vielleicht hat es sie nie gegeben
vielleicht war es auch bei den alten
griechen so dass das was sie erlebt
haben das wäre übrigens wirklich meine
these vermittelt war über die mythen
diese gehört haben nicht diese jungen
griechen am lagerfeuer oder wo auch
immer die in athen dann saßen abends
die hörten geschichten jeden abend jeden
abend stundenlang und alles was sie
erlebt hatten ging in dieses schema
dieser geschichten ein
wir gucken fernsehen wir lesen romane
wir lesen an irgendwelche storys und
diese stories haben scripts und dieses
clips sind nicht unendlich vielfältig es
sind ein paar wenige grundmuster die
immer wieder wiederholt werden neu
angefüllt werden
die nehmen wir allmählich und in uns auf
und dann geht es gar nicht mehr als das
wird die welt durch diese schemata
hindurchsehen einfaches beispiel nur die
liebe ja vielleicht ist das analyse ist
das gar nicht so schlimm ich sage meinen
studenten immer wenn ihr wissen wollt
was liebe ist oder wenn ihr wissen wollt
wie man mit frauen umgeht oder wie man
mit einem chef umgeht dann geht ins kino
aber das macht ja ohnehin ja da wird es
gezeigt wird das stereotyp natürlich
ganz banalisiert oft und in einfachen
strukturen aber es wird gezeigt und wir
eignen uns das an und probieren es aus
und es gibt dazu eigentlich keine
alternative
gehen sie ins kino und lernen sich mit
dem chef umgehen sagen sie sozusagen mal
vor schon früher war ja weil die
literatur war war das theater war die
moralische anstalt und deswegen darum
sich zu vergnügen sich moralisch quasi
aus weiterzubilden
auf der anderen seite sagen sie genau
dass die medien sich auf das
moralisieren quasi reduzieren dass man
dass die medien die welt in gut und böse
einteilen in opfer und täter und das
wird auch durch eine sehr einfache sicht
auf die welt haben möchte ist das nun
kritik oder ist das einfach eine
neutrale feststellung ich versuche
allgemein mich in die darstellungen der
medien ein bisschen fern zu halten von
medienkritik
hinnüber fließt und zwar schon seit
jahrzehnten und keinerlei effekt hat für
effekt das ist so schwer zu sagen weil
ich nicht daran glaube dass ist denkbar
ist kann es mir auch schwer imaginieren
aber oft würde ich mir vor allen dingen
in deutschland tatsächlich eher so naht
angelsächsischen nachrichten spiel
wünschen also wirklich an den fakten
orientiert und dann einen großen strich
zu machen so wie das früher in den
zeitungen war und darunter dann meine
meinung
genau davon sind wir in deutschland
leider gottes sehr sehr weit entfernt
ich will darüber aber auch nicht jammern
das hat historische gründe
ich hätte schon gewisse ideen was man
vielleicht besser machen könnte vor
allen dingen bin ich der an der
auffassung das ist ein großer irrtum ist
wie wir das in deutschland nach wie vor
tun dass man glaubt das fernsehen müsste
das medium sein in dem man eine arme
geistig notleidende bevölkerung
gewissermaßen mit einem minimum an
kultur versorgt also diese berühmte
kulturauftrag des deutschen fernsehens
da habe ich große zweifel ob das
vernünftig ist ich werde er für
polarisierung also gerade beiden
gebührenfinanzierten fernsehen wir
unseren würde ich sagen mehr philosophie
aber auch mehr nonsens ja mehr sport
also alles was spaß macht was gewisse
leute fasziniert weniger mittelmäßigkeit
das wäre vielleicht meine zentrale aber
auch einzige kritik alles wenn sie so
wollen extreme es kann interessant sein
sollte man ausprobieren
aber dieses zeigte mittelmäßigkeit das
ist etwas was mich doch sehr nervt sie
waren beim moralismus stecken geblieben
ich komme auf diese mittelmäßigkeit
zurück eben die welt wahrnehmen durch
gute böse opfer täter ist problematisch
sie sagen sogar an einer stelle
wer nach moral ruft will sich das denken
ersparen heißt das dass moralische
urteile kein denken voraussetzen
das haben sie das haben sie messerscharf
beschlossen nein das mache ich natürlich
nicht sagen ich urteile auch moralisch
dass es doch selbstverständlich ich bin
interviewt worden zu dem fall dati wie
jeder mensch
wird heute zu dem fall und habe da
natürlich eine radikal moralische
meinung dazu
nur würde ich die gerne unterschieden
sehen von nachrichten oder in dem fall
etwa der juristischen dimension dieses
falls sie würden sie in dem fall
argumentieren einerseits moralisch
andererseits juristisch moralisch würde
ich sagen schweinerei der mann ist für
mich gestorben ich habe sowieso nichts
mit ihm zu tun möchte aber auch niemals
etwas mit solchen typen zu tun haben
schrecklich dass es solche leute gibt
auf der anderen seite scheint es so zu
sein als ginge es juristisch nicht um
ein straftatbestand
dann ist das umgekehrt eine schweinerei
wie die staatsanwaltschaft vorgeht und
diese dinge also so differenzieren zu
können wenn man so will den atem und die
differenziertheit zu haben zu sagen das
ist die eine dimension es gibt aber auch
eine andere dimension also ein bisschen
besonnenheit reflexion abstand zu dem
was man präsentiert das ist etwas was
man gott sei dank auch noch findet es
gibt ja noch diese berühmten
qualitätszeitungen ja das will ich sage
ich ohne ironie das gibt es gott sei
dank noch aber der mainstream der
massenmedien der in dem konvergieren
doch darstellung information und
moralisches urteil immer mehr eine der
interessantesten fälle der gerade diese
tage abgeschlossen wurde ist die frei
die freisprechung von ehemaligen
bundespräsidenten wulff dem man
korruption vorgeworfen hatte am schluss
hat sich diese dieser riesen vorwurf auf
ein paar euro reduziert und heute und
nun wurde er freigesprochen
ist das auch ein beispiel dafür dass man
in warum moral sehr schnell handelt ohne
dass man eben wirklich erst mal die
fakten sprechen lässt der fall hat
unendlich viele dimensionen darüber
könnten wir die ganze sendung
diskutieren ich will es kurz machen wie
es sich für mich darstellt
der fall wulff ist ein interessanter
fall gerade deshalb weil es keinerlei
juristische verfehlungen gibt ehrlich
gesagt habe ich das von anfang an
vermutet und viele andere auch was wulff
nicht etwa aus der bredouille
herausbringt jetzt wird's erst für den
medienwissenschaftler interessant
nämlich wolf hat im glauben im recht zu
sein wäre ausreichend sich so
ungeschickt verhalten dass er sich
selber aus seinem amt katapultiert hat
und sein image vollkommen zu
dort hat das heißt er hat alles falsch
gemacht im der auseinandersetzung mit
einer von massenmedien bestimmten
öffentlichkeit was man überhaupt noch
falsch machen kann
aber die gegenspieler die
staatsanwaltschaft genauso sie haben
auch alles falsch gemacht was man falsch
machen kann
offensichtlich aus einer gewissen medien
geilheit heraus diese leute wollen wir
amerikanische staatsanwälte auch in die
öffentlichkeit und wollen dort wirken
und haben eben auch wenn man so will das
fundamentale handwerkszeug nicht mehr
richtig beherrscht nämlich solide
aufzuklären aufzuarbeiten und immer auch
im auge zu behalten was im deutschen
rechtssystem fundamental ist dass
staatsanwälte nicht nur belasten das
sondern auch entlastendes material zu
sichten haben also alle haben das falsch
gemacht wenn man so will und das war ein
gefundenes fressen für die medien die
leben natürlich von skandalen und
mittlerweile eben nicht nur die
sogenannten boulevard-medien denn es
gibt einen prozess der boulevardisierung
aller medien und nur noch ganz ganz
wenig widerstand gibt es in den letzten
seriösen ecken wie die neue züricher faz
oderbruch in nehmen wir genau dieses
wort widerstand auf sie haben den
begriff schon genannt konformismus
sie zeichnen sich dadurch aus dass sie
versuchen oft eine gegenmeinung zu
vertreten sie vertreten die auch sehr
deutlich sie haben beispielsweise gesagt
eben authenzität ist da eines der großen
schlagworte nachhaltigkeit ist ein
anderes sie positionieren sich just am
anderen ende nachhaltigkeit behalten sie
für nachher zu ökologischen
fundamentalismus wenn man so will
wie begründen sie das beziehungsweise wo
wie viel an ihrer position ist gegen
provokation und wie viel ist wirklich
philosophie ja das ist jetzt natürlich
schwer für mich zu beurteilen also
objektiv über mich zu urteilen was so
eine zentrale frage betrifft aber
zumindest was mein selbstverständnis
betrifft hat das mit gegen provokation
überhaupt nichts zu tun
bleiben wir bei dem beispiel
nachhaltigkeit das habe ich relativ früh
aufgegriffen als thema das liegt glaube
ich 18 jahre zurück wenn ich mich recht
erinnere damals war ich an der essener
universität und wurde von einer
großveranstaltungen angefragt ob ich
nicht zum thema sustainability einen
vortrag halten würde
und ich habe dann gesagt ich kann gerne
einen vortrag halten so aus kollegialer
freundlichkeit aber ich könnte nur etwas
über ein system ability sagen also warum
es nicht geht und das hing damit
zusammen dass ich mich wissenschaftlich
mit dem thema beschäftigt hatte rasch
herausgefunden hatte dass der begriff
aus der forstwirtschaft und dann aber
auch recht festgestellt habe dass in
komplexen systemen so etwas wie
nachhaltigkeit unmöglich ist damals
hatte ich sehr intensiven kontakt mit
der sogenannten systemtheorie der
gesellschaft die unsere unsere welt als
welt von komplexen systemen schildert
mit einer sehr eigenen dynamik die auf
jeden fall nicht auf diese wunderbaren
gleichgewichts modelle zurückzuführen
ist der mathematiker thom hat einmal
eine so genannte katastrophen theorie
aufgestellt als mathematiker und er
meint damit nicht die spektakulären
fernseh katastrophen wie tsunamis oder
sowas sondern er meinte einfach extremer
form von unordnung hat dann gesagt
dynamische systeme wie unsere moderne
gesellschaft stürzen gewissermaßen von
unordnung zu unordnung ja und dieses
diese bewegung ist die normalität
das klingt nicht besonders nett ich weiß
genau natürlich jeder nicht nur jeder
manager jede lehrerin hat heute das
lieblingswort nachhaltigkeit und das
wort wird in den absurdesten
kombinationen mittlerweile benutzt weil
es beruhigt das klingt einfach schon
forstwirtschaftlich so unendlich
beruhigen das wächst was nach und alles
ist balanciert aber das interessante es
eben gerade dass die grundgedanke der
grünen nämlich es gebe eine balance
zwischen gesellschaft und umwelt im
sinne von natur dass der sich nicht
verträgt mit der theorie komplexer
systeme das auszusprechen ist eigentlich
sache von wissenschaftlern würde ich
sagen aber leider gottes gibt es
unendlich viele die gefälligkeits
wissenschaftler geworden sind also genau
das aussprechen
und mit wissenschaftlichen formeln wenn
man so will garnieren was politiker vor
allen dingen aber eben auch eine erregte
öffentlichkeit gerne hören möchte
insofern sehe ich da bin keine gegen
provokation da fühle ich mich eigentlich
als wissenschaftler wenn ich sage das
gibt es nicht jetzt haben sie andere
themen die etwas provokativer sind wenn
sie man muss ja nicht für die
frauenquote sein aber sie sind ja
bekannt dafür dass sie für eine
traditionelle familienmodell einstehen
dass sie finden sie haben auch drei
töchter vier tschuldigung sie haben
offenbar auch eine frau die zu hause ist
und so arbeitet sie finden das gut
um das mal ganz generell zu sagen ist
das auch jetzt eine wissenschaftliche
darstellung dieser position oder haben
sie da auch eine ganz persönliche
darstellung ist das nicht und nun diese
provokation ist etwas da gemüt ist den
ersten satz oder die erste seite des
buchs helden der familie zu lesen in dem
ich klipp und klar schreibe ich habe
dieses buch geschrieben einfach um
frauen die ähnliche erfahrungen machen
wie meine eigene frau ein bisschen mut
zu machen nämlich ständig reduziert zu
werden und lächerlich gemacht zu werden
von den berufstätigen frauen und nicht
glaube er dass das gefühl so ist
lächerlich gemacht zu werden das ist die
frau das kind wahrscheinlich das sind
wahrscheinlich persönliche erfahrungen
gibt es millionenfach so oder so ja denn
die berufstätigen frauen sagen ja genau
das gegenteil wir werden immer als
rabenmütter denunziert und antworten
frauen habe ich sowieso nicht leicht
frauen haben das meine ich allerdings
ist voll im ernst ich glaube es gibt
nichts schwierigeres als das heute
frau zu sein ja also ich gott sei dank
bleibt wäre sein part aber ich beobachte
ist ja an meiner eigenen familie
das ist verdammt schwer wegen der
rollenerwartungen und der rollen
zumutungen die heute so hart sind wie
nur wenn ich sehe das recht sich in der
kulturgeschichte noch nie zuvor aber um
zurückzukommen auf das motiv meines
buchs ich habe zwar leid getan ich habe
ein persönliches motiv das buch zu
schreiben wenn man so will für meine
frau und alle frauen die in einer
ähnlichen situation sind wenn sie so
wollen die berühmten hausfrauen und
mütter und wollte ihnen sagen hier wenn
ihr argumentationshilfe braucht und so
verstehe ich übrigens alle meine bücher
ebenfalls die der letzten 20 jahre
hier nimmt das ja auch hier abc der
medien für meine eigenen studenten
geschrieben ich weiß sind die theorien
viel zu komplex die mit denen er
konfrontiert wird hier wenn ihr lust
habt ich mache es etwas einfacher
das sind die wesentlichen fakes und die
wesentlichen theorien genauso weit im
buch über die familie dass das war eine
art handreichung für menschen die
gewisse empfindungen haben gefühle haben
auch das gefühl haben ich mag es
eigentlich richtig warum habe ich so ein
schlechtes standing in der gesellschaft
und ich sage dann hier hast du argumente
ich glaube die kannst du nachvollziehen
und mit denen kannst du arbeiten das ist
für mich ein tolles gefühl muss ich ganz
ehrlich sagen also dieser gedanke dass
da irgend eine hausfrau oder mutter die
wütend ist über diese situation in der
sie lebt nicht etwa als hausfrau und
mutter sondern in der gesellschaft die
das nicht glücklich waren sie ist das
nicht ich glaube nein das so kann man
das glaube ich nicht sagen so wie ich
das war nehme ist es etwas anders und
das buch hat übrigens auch in ganz
anderen thema
das hat nicht den tenor zurück zur alten
familie und da ich befürchtet habe dass
es so verstanden werden könnte vor allen
dingen von denen jeden dies nicht
richtig lesen weil sie dazu keine zeit
haben habe ich den satz auch vier oder
fünfmal reingeschrieben wortwörtlich es
gibt kein zurück zur traditionellen
familie dieser satz steht vier oder fünf
mal klipp und klar drin also kein
rollback es ist ein traditionelles
modell
ich habe nur ein plädoyer entwickelt und
auch das steht klipp und klar
dessen buch und mehrfach dafür lasst die
leute die so leben wollen und so leben
können das ist auch eine geldfrage
lasst sie doch lasst sie doch in ruhe
haben sie nun da wurde vieles das nicht
der fall ist wir haben schon das gefühl
dass diese menschen müssen so léon geben
konkretes beispiel als wir nach berlin
zogen haben wir große schwierigkeiten
gehabt ersten schulen zu finden und dann
kindergarten noch für das kleinste kind
zu finden
und dann hatten wir ein kind das so in
der grundschule ist und da machten wir
diese wunderbare erfahrung erster du
kannst gerne zu uns kommen aber nur
unter der bedingung dass du auch der
dumpf das volle betreuungsangebot
wahrnimmst das heißt also man hat ihnen
klar gemacht was wir von ihnen erwarten
ist nicht dass sie ihr kind einfach in
die schule bringen sondern das kind soll
dann in der schule auch betreut werden
und das soll dann abends können sich
dann abholen verstehen sie was immer
entstehen im plus während in der schweiz
wären sie zu hause bei der partei die
genaue zurück zu diesem traditionellen
familie das ist nicht anders als den
meisten mit denen ich schon gesprochen
habe sie sind durch das thema natürlich
auch sehr stark erregt und deshalb fällt
es schwer zu differenzieren ich kann das
natürlich viel zu sagen
aber genau das tue ich ja eben nicht ich
sage ja nicht baut keine nicht die kitas
aus oder macht keine ganztagsbetreuung
oder ganztagsschule
ich sage ganz simpel nur lasst doch die
leute das wählen was sie wollen den
lebensentwurf den sie gut finden wenn
sie es gut finden ihr kind nach drei
wochen in eine kita zu bringen oder wie
auch immer man das nennen wir sollen es
ist tun
manche müssen es tun die brauchen
dringend das geld die können sich gar
nicht längeren urlaub oder so
irgendetwas leisten wunderbar wenn es
das gibt ich unterstütze das sehr
nur wenn andere sagen nein ich will mein
kind selber großziehen ich will es so
lange erziehen bis es dann wie früher
hat man gesagt keine kindergarten geht
darf man ja auch nicht mehr sagen heißt
jetzt kita
warum denn nicht warum sollen dem mütter
ihre kinder nicht drei jahre zu hause
erziehen und es dann in den kindergarten
geben warum denn nicht nur das ist das
plädoyer relativ simpel und ich habe ein
paar argumente für diejenigen die so
denken gesammelt und diese argumente
sind allerdings welche die ich gerne
diskutieren würde wollen sie das
wichtigste gleich vorangehen ja
beispielsweise das wichtigste und das
kontrovers ist das sicher was wir sagen
die fetzen fliegen lässt ist das
argument dass kinder von ihren eigenen
eltern besser erzogen werden können und
liebevoller erzogen werden können als
von irgendwelchen pflegepersonen also
die überhaupt keine verwandten
das ist die zentrale überlegung die zum
teil auch heutzutage wird alles von
wissenschaften abgedeckt sie können zu
allem ein gutachten wissen von
wissenschaftlern hat es gibt dazu aber
sehr einschläge untersuchen gerade in
ländern die das jahrzehntelang
praktiziert haben in skandinavien und wo
die stimmen immer lauter werden dass es
einen unterschied gibt zwischen der der
wenn sie so wollen der liebevollen
erziehung und der dem bloßen versorgen
ja also diesen kustodie lka wie man das
in amerika nennt
und ich finde das einigermaßen
nachvollziehbar dass das nicht an
kindern spurlos vorübergeht ob sie
entweder gehätschelt und geliebt werden
von ihren eigenen eltern oder ob sie
wenn sie so wollen betreut werden und
wie es oft doch auch wirkliches verwahrt
werden dass das nicht dasselbe ist
glaube ich ist eigentlich unstrittig man
streitet über die folgen das gebe ich
gerne zu aber ich würde sagen so ein
argument ist doch nachvollziehbar oder
das ist ein gedanke der es wert ist
durchdacht zu werden und genau das
schlage ich als ich meine wollen wir
jetzt da wirkt wollen da jetzt mal nicht
darüber diese studien das behaupten die
das gegenteil behaupten diskutieren das
ist die frage ist ja je nachdem
gehen wir davon aus gehen wir davon aus
es gibt unterschiede familien
hintergründen es gibt kinder denen diese
liebevolle erziehung wie sie sie nennen
zuteil kommen und es gibt kinder denen
diese nicht zuteil schon und reis ja die
frage sieht sich eine gesellschaft in
der verantwortung da irgendetwas für
diese kinder zu tun und aus dem heraus
ist ja so etwas wie ein sozialstaat
erwachsen aus dem heraus ist die
betreuung für kinder erwachsen aus dem
heraus ist beispielsweise auch die
aufgabe oder die notwendigkeit erkannt
worden dass man kinder früh in der
schule neben da neben dem eigentlichen
unterricht die sprache das
sozialverhalten und so weiter dass man
sehen dass mit gehen soll
würden sie denn das jetzt verurteilen
dass man das tut was man diese
möglichkeit hoffe dass es nicht jetzt zu
unhöflich wenn ich sage allein dass sie
mir die stelle frage stellen zeigt dass
sie sich nicht mehr erinnern können was
in dem buch steht denn es steht explizit
drinnen dass ich das gut finde ich bin
ein verteidiger des sozialstaates
im gegenteil alles was auch ein lauter
kritik an alles was ich nicht ein lauter
kritiker des sozialstaates sondern ich
bin ein kritiker eines sozialstaates der
sich übernimmt und deshalb seine
eigentliche funktion gar nicht mehr
erfüllen kann
meine eigentliche funktion bezeichnet
die eigentliche funktion ist der schutz
der wirklich hilfsbedürftigen natürlich
sicherheit und ordnung wie man das
früher zu recht gefordert hat und
natürlich der schutz des einzelnen und
seines eigentums das sind die
wesentlichen funktionen eines staates
ich habe in einem anderen buch sehr
ausführlich die geschichte des
sogenannten sozialen rechtsstaats
geschildert was ich für eine geniale
erfindung der grundgesetz weiter nach
dem zweiten weltkrieg halte und ihr habt
gesagt wenn wir dazu team zurück kämen
zu der reflektiert hyde der menschen die
in den 50er jahren dieses gebilde
entwickelt haben im vollen bewusstsein
seiner problematik dann würden unendlich
viele diskussionen heute überflüssig
werden also ich bin gerade jemand der
versucht die überlebensfähigkeit des
sozialstaates zu sichern denn das wird
ihnen nicht entgangen sein
es fehlt ihm an geld und zwar von jahr
zu jahr mehr und er wird immer unfähiger
seine fundamentalen leistungen zu
erbringen also gerade weil ich finde das
ist keine frage der barmherzigkeit
sondern einer sozialen regulierung als
derigs
tendenzen die sich nicht mehr selbst
helfen können ja das ist das dringendste
was überhaupt nötig ist das macht den
sozialstaat aus aber das setzt voraus
dass er nicht in einer art imperial
overstreet überall hinein reguliert wo
er überhaupt nichts zu suchen hat und
ganz gesund das ist für meine begriffe
das zentrale politische problem heute
jetzt ein thema oder sagen wir einen
meter thema zieht sich ja bei ihnen
immer durch ob wir über authentizität
sprechen ob wir über nachhaltigkeit
sprechen ob wir über das familienmodell
sprechen oder über den sozialstaat sie
vertreten eine andere meinung sie haben
das wort selber schon genannt als
domains was wie würden sie den
mainstream umschreiben und warum es ist
wichtig eine andere meinung zu vertreten
warum ist es auch schwierig den
mainstream sich hingegen zu stellen nun
ich kann da natürlich gewinnen nur über
deutschland sprechen weil ich da nur
einschlägige erfahrungen gemacht habe
der mainstream ist bei uns sehr stark
geprägt von den intellektuellen also
wenn ich mainstream als veröffentlichte
meinung zunächst einmal begreifen und es
gibt tatsächlich so eine art system der
diffusion der öffentlichen meinung
geprägt ursprünglich von den
intellektuellen dieser intellektuellen
hatten sehr sehr früh schon erkannt wie
wichtig es ist in die institutionen zu
gehen dass der persönliche 70er jahre
folgen genau der marschmusik
leider stimmt das nicht ganz ich gehör
nur zu den sogenannten zaungästen also
die 68er sind ein bisschen älter als ich
und ich habe sie nur als meine älteren
brüder gewissermaßen wahrgenommen und
auch bewundert selbstverständlich und
viel von ihnen gelernt aber der von
dutschke ausgerufene marsch durch die
institutionen hat wirklich stattgefunden
und das hat zumindest in deutschland
dazu geführt dass diese intellektuellen
und zum teil noch wenn sie es wollen in
der form von in der person von jürgen
habermas bis zum heutigen tag noch ein
schalthebeln zumindest der
intellektuellen macht und der
öffentlichen meinung sitzen und die
haben unendlich viele jünger rekrutiert
wenn sie wollen
in den parteien natürlich sind die sind
auch alle in die spd eingegangen später
dann natürlich zu den grünen
sie sind natürlich auch in die
rundfunkanstalten gegangen in die medien
und da üben die in der tat eine art
generationen herrschaft aus jetzt
allmählich sterben sie aus und ich bin
gespannt ob das wirklich eine wende
bringt ich bin da recht optimistisch
sogar aber über jahrzehnte hinweg haben
hat diese generation geherrscht und sie
hat vor allen dingen die öffentliche
meinung beherrscht und gegen dieses
kartell der öffentlichen meinung dieser
wächter generation wie peter vorzimmer
genannt hat gegen dieses kartell
anzudenken ist schon schwer und dagegen
an zu sprechen war lange zeit unmöglich
und sie tun es trotzdem vehement und
eigentlich immer wieder
ja ich habe einfach auch ein
wahnsinniges glück dass ich bei einem
verlag bin der einfach druck was ich
schreibe dafür bin ich dankbar
ich weiß gar nicht was aus mir geworden
wäre wenn der fink verlag nicht einen
narren an mir gefressen hätte und meine
sachen gebracht sie produzieren ja auch
sozusagen am laufenden band alexis de
tocqueville der die demokratie in
amerika untersucht und beschrieben hat
1835 darüber geschrieben hat hat von der
sogenannten tyrannei der mehrheit
gesprochen er hat gesagt eine
bevölkerung oder ein staat der seine
bürger über alles abstimmung bestimmen
lässt läuft irgendwann gefahr dass sich
die der mainstream einander nicht so
einander ist die tyrannei der mehrheit
dass sie sich durchsetzt haben sie das
gefühl dass das was sie beschreiben
natürlich fühlen sie das auf das
mediensystem zurück aber haben sie auch
das gefühl dass es mit unserem
politischen system zu tun hat nein
ehrlich gesagt nicht es hat nichts mit
demokratie zu tun auch nicht mit der
sogenannten mediendemokratie
die politiker sind da ausnahmsweise mal
schuldlos würde ich sagen an diesem
prozess es geht um den prozess der
öffentlichen meinung auf denen die
politik ihrerseits reagiert
also die politiker correctness was
sicher die wichtigste kraft in diesem
zusammenhang innerhalb der letzten 20
jahre war diese politische correctness
kommt nicht aus den parlamenten ganz im
gegenteil nein die kommt vom krampus sie
kommt vom universitäts gelände zunächst
in amerika aber dann ganz ganz rasch
auch in deutschland und mittlerweile in
der ganzen welt und diese politische
correctness die ursprünglich mal sehr
sehr gute sinnvolle argumente hatte auch
dieses kann es ging eher darum
beispielsweise den schwarzen den frauen
gleiche rechte zu geben und das auch
sprachlich quasi bewusst zu lassen ist
vollkommen ruhig stellen studenten und
studentinnen sprechen wollen dann wollen
wir uns auch mit gehört das ist absolut
richtig und das war hatte vor allen
dingen in amerika natürlich einen
unendlich guten sinn und hat auch
positive effekte gezeigt
allerdings ist das sehr sehr rasch
umgeschlagen in einer absurditäten und
da sind wir bei dem stichwort dass sie
vorhin schon gegeben haben mit der quote
natürlich bin ich nicht gegen die
frauenquote sondern ich bin gegen quoten
überhaupt also ich bin schlicht dagegen
dass menschen als gruppen angehörige
behandelt werden und nicht als
individuen
sie können das idealistisch nennen oder
wenn man so will als liberal oder wie
auch immer
aber für mich sind prix mit menschen
primär individuen und sollen als
individuen beurteilt werden wenn ich
irgendjemanden einstelle bei mir dann
möchte ich dass der beste oder die beste
den job kriegt und ich habe es fast nur
noch mit frauen zu tun was sie angenehm
ist und nicht deshalb weil sie in der
spd ist oder weil sie den dänen und den
hintergrund hat oder
migrationshintergrund oder was auch
immer diese ganze diskussion die ganze
quotendiskussion ist eine vergewaltigung
der individuen und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen widersprechen sie wir jetzt
sie ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
jemand der durch diese quotenregelung zu
irgendeinem job oder zu einem status
gekommen ist damit wirklich glücklich
wird ich habe es auch noch nie erlebt
ganz im gegenteil
ich versteh ich verstehe ihre
argumentation wenn ich ihnen
widersprechen würde würde ich so
widersprechen dass ich sage es kann ja
wenn wir wiederum die wissenschaft so
hilfe holen es kann ja rein statistisch
nicht sein dass es so viel bessere
männer gibt die eben in diese
führungsposition kommen als es frauen
gibt rein statistisch ist das nicht
möglich also muss irgendwo auf dem
lebensweg etwas passieren dass frauen
nicht im gleichen maße da vertreten sind
das ist doch nur zu genau
ja und wenn das selbstverständlich ist
dann ist die frage und wenn es uns trotz
allen anstrengungen mit mentoring
programmen mit allem möglichen was wir
in den letzten jahrzehnten gesehen haben
nicht gelungen ist mehr frauen in diese
führungsebenen ich spreche jetzt von der
werden muss beispielsweise zu bringen
dann muss man sich schon fragen wenn das
immer noch nicht erfüllt werden wenn da
immer noch ein falsches bild der
eigentlichen kompetenzen sich zeigen
dann muss irgendetwas dann müssen wir
eine herb dann müssen wir einen einen
stärkeren kniff quasi finden
darum geht es ja es geht es um die funde
hingelegt und zu vergewaltigen
es geht darum chancengleichheit auch auf
der stufe zu schaffte ebene der
vorstände haben auch carina zu
vorständen von großunternehmen nichts
sagen weil ich noch nie drin war und
weil ich nicht weiß wie die sich
rekrutieren keine ahnung ich will lieber
ein beispiel bringen aus der welt die
ich kenne offenbar ebenfalls rekrutieren
sie sich so dass frauen weniger
zuschauer ich habe natürlich vermutungen
womit das zusammenhängen könnte
beispielsweise mit aggressivität könnte
es zusammenhängen die wenn man so will
kampfbereitschaft oder auf der anderen
seite dann auch
kommunikationsbereitschaft frauen haben
ganz offensichtlich pflege da gerne
dieses vorurteil weil es ja nicht
unfreundlich ist vorsprung in sachen
kommunikative steht also sie frauen sind
kommunikativer sie haben auch kröten
offenbar mehr lust am kommunizieren als
die meisten männer männer neigen glaube
ich doch nach wie vor mehr und das
könnte sogar hormonelle gründe haben zu
aggressivität und zur aggressiven
durchsetzungs verhalten also weniger zur
verhandlungslösungen und ähnlichem mehr
daraus könnte man kulturell den schluss
ziehen lasst doch die frauen machen
dann gibt es weniger kriege dann gibt es
weniger konflikte und ähnliches mehr mag
sein vielleicht sogar eine vernünftige
politische per
effektiver aber auf jeden fall bedeutet
dass überall da wo es um knappe
ressourcen geht und wo man mit
aggressionen tatsächlich erfolgreich
sein kann würde es mich nicht
überraschen wenn sich am ende wieder
männer durchsetzen oder eben frauen die
es so sehr diese männer attitüde
verinnerlicht haben dass man sie dann
oft in ihrer weiblichkeit gar nicht mehr
wieder erkennen dass sich auch viele
studien gibt das genau unternehmen die
mehr frauen in führungsetagen haben
mindestens erfolgreich sind wenn ich zur
folge aus dem grunde den ich ja gerade
genannt habe weil ich gesagt habe es
gibt diese politische überlegungen das
womöglich größere kooperativität größere
kommunikative steht auch für eine
organisation hilfreich ist und dass man
nicht alles mit den ellbogen machen muss
darüber will ich hätte ich überhaupt
keine eile sagt aber das interessante
ist dass in dem system das sich immer am
erfolg und ist nämlich am finanziellen
erfolg wo sich genau ein solcher evidenz
zeigt auch dieses system nicht auf die
evidenz sich einlässt also das ist ja
warum man überhaupt wenn es ein event
ist dann ist es den leuten
offensichtlich doch nicht evident dann
überlegen sie mal ein wenig überlegen
sie mal eines ich würde sagen in
bereichen wie der universität wenn es da
was es gar nicht gibt bei uns jedenfalls
nicht nach wie vor eine systematische
benachteiligung von frauen gäbe könnte
man so ein typischer staatsbetrieb da
kommt es auf leistung nicht an da können
die machen was sie wollen aber in der
wirtschaft geht das doch wirklich um
profit also wir leben doch im
kapitalismus kann das wirklich sein dass
auf lange sicht man die dümmeren leute
an die entscheidenden positionen setzt
obwohl klügere frauen für unendlich viel
mehr profit und für viel mehr
geschäftserfolg sorgen gebe es das gebe
ihnen nur ein beispiel hat in
norditalien die frauenquote eingesetzt
und durchgesetzt für politische listen
und was ist passiert die qualifikation
des personals auf diesen politischen
ließ dresden hat sich schlagartig
gesteigert nicht ganz einfach können wir
sind es bei uns zu hause das war jetzt
er gerade gesehen haben oder bei ist
eben wirklich an der qualifikation ist
beides automatisch der pool vergrößert
und weil man dadurch der wettbewerb
größer werde was also sage ist in der
bürger anteil an der wirtschaft läuft es
mir am wenigsten
die quotenregelung weil gerade die
wirtschaft profit orientiert ist und man
ein idiot wäre einen besseren oder eine
bessere nicht zu holen
es gibt eine riesengroße jagd in der
weltwirtschaft wenn sie so wollen wo
sind die klügsten leute wo sind die
tollsten köpfe glauben sie im ernst es
gebe kluge intelligente weibliche köpfe
die man sehenden auges nicht einstellen
würde nur weil sie frauen sind
das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen so
dumm sind die leute nicht in der
wirtschaft
ich habe das immer wieder sagt
vorstellen könnte mir vorstellen oder in
staatsbetrieben oder so irgendetwas aber
noch nicht da wo gedeih und verderb
eines unternehmens auf dem markt
entschieden wird wo markterfolg über
alles entscheiden
da sucht man die besten leute und wenn
die erfahrung sich breiter durchsatz
wenn man an vielen firmen das beobachten
kann dass sobald frauen da das sagen
haben die wirtschaft auch erfolgreicher
ist dann wird sich das durchsetzen und
das wäre die form die ich für
demokratisch und für auch kulturell
sinnvoll halte während quotierung immer
undemokratisch ist also es gibt kein
einziges demokratisches argument das für
die quote spricht
lassen wir das für den moment zu stehen
wir können es nicht lösen heute
jedenfalls können sie streiten und sie
wollen streiten und sie haben aber das
letzte buch was sie geschrieben haben
das richtige leben
da zeigen sich von einer völlig anderen
seite
sie sind bekannt als norbert bolz der
sich in den medien ereifert über themen
wie wir das soeben mitbekommen haben der
sich nicht scheut eine andere meinung zu
vertreten der das sehr lautstark macht
und da reflektieren sie über das
richtige leben darüber was ist
eigentlich heißt sein leben so zu
gestalten wie es für ein richtig ist ist
das buch eine alterserscheinung sie
haben ja davor ja das ist eine
alterserscheinung eindeutig nein ganz im
ernst ich hatte ja vorhin schon gesagt
als ich 50 wurde habe ich mich
entschlossen jetzt sagst du schreibst du
nur noch was du wirklich denkst und als
sich 60 wurde habe ich mich entschlossen
jetzt schreibst du mal über ein thema
das für dich wirklich existenziell
wichtig ist und ich gehöre ja zu den
abonnenten also zu den adorno an
tränen weil sie haben ja gesagt die 68er
sind älter als sie hört sie haben über
theodor adorno hat der große kritische
denken
das stimmt und für mich war natürlich
auch adorno mars gibt lange lange zeit
und einer seiner berühmtesten sätze
lautet natürlich es gibt kein richtiges
leben im falschen ja also wir leben in
einer falschen gesellschaft in einen
verblendung zusammenhang wie es damals
hieß und innerhalb dieses verblendung
zusammenhang es kannst du gar kein
richtiges leben leben das hat wunderbar
eingeleuchtet und dass das ist ja auch
ein wunderbar formulierter satz aber er
hat ich habe ihn nie so recht glauben
können und deshalb hat mich das thema
eigentlich immer schon interessiert was
ja wie sie wissen dass ethische thema
schlechthin nichten ist nämlich wie lebt
man richtig was ist das richtige leben
ist die ethische grundfragen schlechthin
interessanterweise hat die ethik schon
sehr früh abschied genommen von dieser
ihrer eigenen zentralen frage in den
letzten jahrhunderten taucht das
nirgendwo mehr wieder auf niemand kein
philosoph hat ernsthaft darüber
nachgedacht
man hat das feld überlassen dem pseudo
philosophen denen die philosophische
ratgeber schreiben oder so was was ist
glück oder so irgendetwas können sie an
jeder bahnhofsbuchhandlung kaufen und
oder machiavelli für frauen oder für
manager oder so irgendetwas kurzum die
zentrale ethische frage nämlich die
frage nach dem richtigen leben ist von
der ethik seit jahrhunderten nicht mehr
behandelt worden
das hat gute gründe das hat gründe dass
man dann nur noch gefragt hat wie
formuliere ich setze als ethisches sätze
oder so irgendetwas noch logischen
inkonsistenzen gesucht hat und ähnliches
mehr
aber im grunde ist er damit die frage
nicht aus der welt eigentlich brennt die
jedem auf den nägeln wie könnte ich
richtig leben und natürlich weiß ich das
auch nicht aber ich habe mir überlegt
ich könnte doch mal gucken wie diese
frage früher beantwortet worden ist und
welche lebensformen welche lebensführung
strippen es eigentlich schon gegeben hat
die vielleicht auch heute noch nicht
vorbildlich sein können aber doch senat
maßstab abgeben könnten für das eigene
leben und das war mein
die idee sich isolieren beschreiben vier
dürfen darin genau der ganz alte typ ist
der held den wirklich noch aus der
griechischen sage kein halten sie nicht
mehr für ganz so aktuell
ein weiterer ein weiteres modell ist das
politische leben in der politik und es
darum entscheidungen zu fällen also man
kann sich den wichtigen fragen nicht im
ziel
sie plädieren aber vor allem für das
bürgerliche leben und da frage ich mich
schon wenn man das liest sie als
abonnent wie sie sich überschrieben
haben eben dieses dieser dieser
kritische blick auf die welt auf die
gesellschaft und dann dieses bild war
für den rückzug in ein bürgerliches
leben sie beschreiben es wirklich als
pflichterfüllung die einen erfüllt die
pflichterfüllung erfüllt einen der die
tägliche arbeit erfüllt einem ist das
jetzt konservativ oder ist das einfach
auch eine kapitulation vor den vielen
möglichkeiten dieser eigentlich gibt es
wird ihnen nicht entgangen sein dass
auch der die bürgerliche lebensform die
als letzte beschrieben wird im rückblick
beschrieben wird
ich orientiere mich ja buchstäblich auch
an thomas manns buddenbrooks und da muss
man sich nur das erscheinungsdatum
anschauen dieses buch ist über 100 jahre
alt und berichtet schon rückblickend auf
eine untergegangene welt des bürgertums
das heißt schon vor 100 jahren war die
welt des bürgertums längst untergegangen
wenn ich also nun diese figuren wenn man
so will heraufbeschwöre dann natürlich
nicht in dem wahnsinnigen glauben
genauso könnte man leben
mir ist das wohl vertraut dass das nicht
geht es gibt weder den waren politiker
noch gibt das den philosophen oder den
weisen der in irgendwelchen gärten seine
philosophen existenz praktiziert all das
wäre wenn man das unmittelbar es
versuchen würde lächerlich und peinlich
aber ich glaube doch dass sie maßstäbe
abgeben die alle vier typen das geben
maßstäbe an denen man das was man selber
tut und wie man sein eigenes leben
versteht durchaus messen kann
also es gibt dinge die vielleicht nicht
umsetzbar sind in die eigene
lebenspraxis aber die einem einer art
lackmus test bieten für das was man
selber tut und wie man selber denkt und
selbst erhält
ist etwas was für mich nicht einfach
untergegangen ist und das sehen sie ja
daran dass wir immer noch helden
verehren und verehren wollen und sei es
wenigstens im fußball oder auf der
leinwand wir wir identifizieren uns mit
helden man zumindest manchmal können wir
uns diese identifikation wir haben
sehnsucht nach diesen helden obwohl wir
gleichzeitig wissen es kann sie gar
nicht mehr im klassischen zu energie es
ist denn auch diese abfolge man neigt er
dazu diese abfolge auch darin so
interpretieren dass man sagt ja klar in
der jugend finden das ungestüme leben
eines helden möchte irgendwann fängt man
darüber nachzudenken alles philosoph
dann wird man politisch und wenn man
eben älter werden selbst dann quasi kann
man sich auch ein bisschen in ruhe
zurückziehen ist das eine normale
biografie gibt die philosophie quasi
diese normale biografie wieder toll zu
haben dass als erste gemerkt genau so
war es gedacht
also ich wollte es in der tat auch alt
als es aber sein lebensalter abfolge
erst ist man dann wird man philosophisch
philosoph wird man nämlich schon als
junger mann und oder als junge frau und
dann wird man politisch und schließlich
bürgerlich also dass in der tat das wäre
die ideale entwicklung hin zu wollen
aber alles so liebliche ausgedrückt
heißt es man fängt unten links an und
hat oben rechts auf mach das nicht tun
wenn man diese entwicklung nimmt leider
gottes in deutschland gibt es meist die
umgekehrte entwicklung dass viele rechts
anfangen und am ende dann im kreisen
alter irgendwelche linken parolen heraus
trompeten das ist eher ein zeichen für
verdummung aber in der tat ist das eine
entwicklung die ich als ein reifeprozess
begreifen würde aber ich möchte noch mal
wiederholen auch diese bürgerliche welt
wird schon im rückblick beschrieben und
man kann sich nur fragen gibt es da
etwas was zu retten ist oder gibt das
etwas was ich da lernen kann und das
meine ich allerdings schon um nur das
eine beispiel zu nehmen
man kann sich seinen beruf nicht
aussuchen leider gottes
die meisten müssen jobs machen die sie
überhaupt nicht erfüllen und ausfüllen
aber wenn man die chance hat einen beruf
zu ergreifen
mit dem man sich wirklich identifizieren
kann so dass tatsächlich es keinen
unterschied mehr gibt zwischen
arbeitszeit und freizeit
dann ist das eine möglichkeit viele
dieser bürgerlichen tugenden noch einmal
zu etablieren
also dann auch tatsächlich diese
verantwortungsbewusste pflichterfüllung
im eigenen job zum zentrum des eigenen
lebens zu machen all das ist dann
möglich
und im grunde ist auch dass nur ein
plädoyer dafür wenn du es kannst
durch glückliche umstände dann tust dann
ergreift diese chance und verklemmte
diese möglichkeit nicht in dem du dich
irgendwo an irgendeinem mainstream an
hengst und einfach nur nachplappern was
die anderen sagen sie haben um quasi den
kreis zu schließen sie haben als
religionswissenschaftler der
religionswissenschaftler studiert das
religiöse leben kommt in diesem buch aus
guten gründen nicht vor weil sie sagen
das religiöse leben wert geführt man
führt es nicht selber sondern man hat
jemanden was auch immer der einen führt
welche rolle spielt denn religion
überhaupt noch in ihrem leben oder
wurden sie das da ansiedeln im richtigen
leben in meinem eigenen leben spielt
religion schon deshalb eine große rolle
weil meine frau religiös ist sie ist
allerdings katholisch ich bin
evangelisch ich selber kümmere mich wenn
sie so wollen um das problem religion in
form des problems evangelische kirche in
deutschland
die ich in einer bedauernswerten
verfassung sehe und ich leide darunter
wenn zu wollen ich leide unter der art
und weise wie die evangelische kirche
sich in deutschland entwickelt hat nicht
erst in den letzten jahren schon seit
jahrzehnten und leide insgesamt ein
bisschen daran wie die christliche
kirche sich in der modernen welt
versucht zu positionieren
einfach deshalb weil ich glaube sie
bringt sich um alles sie kastriert sich
selbst indem sie sich an versucht an die
moderne anzupassen und das ist auf jeden
fall ein irrweg da würde ich auch ganz
scharfe thesen formulieren da fühle ich
mich sogar sehr sicher in meinen
überlegungen
es kann nicht die aufgabe der religion
seien die außer weltliche werte vertritt
in irgendeiner weise das parteiprogramm
der grünen zu reproduzieren was die
evangelischen die evangelische kirche
deutschland wirklich sehr sehr gerne
macht und es ist oft schwierig deren
verlautbarungen von irgendwelchen
parteiparolen der grünen oder der spd zu
unterscheiden also das ist warten ganz
zum schluss zwischen der bram zum
schluss ebenso schließen das religiöse
leben aus sie haben es angetönt wähle
den beruf wenn du ihn wählen kann sind
also sie plädieren da sehr stark für die
selbstverantwortung ist es das was ja
eigentlich auch jeden mitgeben wollten
und letztlich auch nicht nur quasi den
ab 60 sondern auch schon denen ab 15
oder 20 absolut das tue ich jedenfalls
was bei den studenten betrifft und was
meine eigenen kinder betrifft
ich sage ihnen immer macht das was ihr
leidenschaftlich machen könnt das ist
das wichtigste egal was es ist ihr müsst
keine medienwissenschaftler werden erst
gar keine wissenschaftler werden wenn
das nicht eure welt ist aber das was ihr
tun müsst ihr mit leidenschaft tun sonst
kommt überhaupt nichts raus und ihr
werdet unglücklich gott sei dank leben
wir in einer gesellschaft in einer welt
in der westlichen wohlstands welt wo
diese chance sich für viele menschen
eröffnet nicht für alle welt weiß gott
hin aber doch für viele und ich finde es
ist eine sünde wenn man die möglichkeit
hat und man ergreift zu nicht womit sie
sozusagen eine religiöse note wieder
reingekommen richtig norbert bolz ganz
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
[Musik]
medien als religionsersatz auch dass
seine steile these von norbert bolz mehr
über medientheorie auf unserer kultur
plattform am nächsten sonntag werden sie
eventuell lachen wenn wir von
philosophie räten unsere gäste nämlich
sind franz hohler und emil steinberger
mit ihnen philosophiert juri steiner
unter anderem über das lachen jetzt aber
richten wir unseren blick nach leipzig
dort findet sich zurzeit sehr viel
schweiz und wir begeben uns auf
erkundungstour gibt es eine einheitliche
schweizer literatur max moor besucht
schriftstellerinnen aus allen vier
landesteilen ein roadmovie zur schweizer
die natur